Shahed Alam: In the fall of 2021,
I arrived in the US to visit my parents
after almost two years
of not seeing one another.
I was coming from my home
in Bangalore, in India,
where we were just getting out
of a devastating second wave
of the pandemic.
Within weeks of my arrival,
first my father, then me,
then my mother, all came down with COVID.
And it hit us hard.
My parents' age
and their medical conditions
threatened to make each day
more severe than the last.
And despite my medical training,
I was overwhelmed.
It was a nightmare,
one, I'm guessing,
many of you all have faced.
I tried to get them tested at sites
that were booked for days.
We called their doctors
who were unavailable.
We tried to get monoclonal antibodies,
knowing that with every day that passed,
that treatment became less effective.
And this was all while just trying
to figure out what to eat
and how to make them feel better.
Thankfully, we all recovered.
But I'll never forget the depths
of how alone and helpless I felt.
And my desperation to do
anything I could to help.
Edith Elliott: Like Shahed,
and I'm guessing everyone in this room,
at some point in your life,
you've been in the position
of wanting to do whatever you can
to take care of someone you love.
We're here to talk to you
about how our organization,
Noora Health, is rethinking health care.
And yes, we have nearly
a decade's track record,
we're driven by data
and we leverage technology.
But at the heart of what we do
is a powerful force
that might surprise you.
It's love.
It’s that dogged determination
to get your aging mom’s meds sorted out;
that tenacious energy
to get your kid to the ER.
Like oxygen,
it is essential to our health
and our well-being.
It is ever present, but invisible.
It's the fuel of family advocacy.
And for too long it's either
been seen as a nuisance
or it's been ignored altogether
within health care settings.
When Shahed and I met,
we connected over many things,
but we founded Noora on the shared belief
that love is the most powerful,
untapped resource available.
And when valued and made visible,
it can transform health systems.
SA: We work in India and Bangladesh.
When you stand outside
one of the hospitals where we work,
the first thing
you'll notice is the crowd.
When you walk in, you may see
patients doubled up on beds,
and you'll see hallways and waiting areas
filled with families and their belongings
because they've moved to the hospital
to be there with their loved ones.
Families are spending their time
anxiously waiting
while providers are doing
the best that they can
to keep up with the intense demand.
And we know this will only get worse.
Globally, there will be a shortage
of nearly 18 million health care workers
by 2030.
The systems are overburdened
and this has life and death
consequences for patients.
Every year in South Asia alone,
nearly 1.5 million children
under five die.
And far too many of these deaths
can be prevented
with better health practices at home.
At Noora Health, we train
and we support families
with life-saving skills.
We work with hospitals and clinics
to meet people where they are,
at the patient's bedside, in the hallways,
in the waiting areas.
We train nurses so that they can run
sessions with groups of families
to teach them actionable skills.
Things like wound care
and how to recognize warning signs,
like jaundice in a newborn
or slurred speech for a cardiac patient.
And they leave plenty of time
for questions and demonstrations.
Once families leave home,
we stay connected with them,
sending them messages,
videos and reminders
that are relevant for their loved ones,
and we're on the other side
to answer any questions.
So whether it's new parents,
surgical or oncology patients,
we've seen that this approach works
across all types of care.
Because the common thread
is that loved ones are there,
and they want to help.
EE: Along the way,
we've learned a few things.
First, deep listening is key.
Nurses, patients and families
have guided us.
They are the visionaries.
They make sure our trainings incorporate
objects that people have in their homes,
visuals that people see
in their communities,
and words and phrases
that people actually use
instead of complex medical jargon.
Second, trust and timing
are fundamental to behavior change.
Nurses and health care providers
are the people families trust.
So we work with them
to provide the training
at a time and in a place
where families need it most.
Third, you do not have
to start from scratch.
We're not creating new systems,
we’re building with and through
existing infrastructure.
Yes, Noora is there
to kick-start and support,
but the trainings are designed
and introduced in a way
that ensures they will continue
to run sustainably.
So far we've reached hundreds
of hospitals and clinics
across India and Bangladesh,
and we've helped them
change the way they deliver care.
We’ve trained over 5,000 nurses,
and we've reached
over two million family caregivers.
(Applause)
We have seen that this program
reduces cardiac surgery complications
by 71 percent,
and our early data suggests
that it reduces newborn deaths
by 18 percent.
(Applause)
That would mean that over nine
babies' lives are saved
for every 1,000 live births.
And it's all happening
at an extremely low cost
because the solution
leverages existing resources.
SA: I had the chance to meet Bino.
He's a young man who had heart surgery
at the nearest major hospital to him,
which was in Kolkata.
He was accompanied
by his wife Sunita and his uncle,
and both of them went
through the training.
Later on, when I visited
them in their home,
Sunita had just wrapped up
Bino's wound care,
commenting how she left it undressed,
just like in the training.
She showed me how she used
the thermometer
and how she checked Bino's pulse
and rattled off all of the normal
ranges for blood pressure,
heart rate and temperature.
She told me that they eat
more fish now instead of red meat
and avoided foods with too much vitamin K
because of his new medication.
His uncle told me that they were able
to avoid going to the local clinic
every single time they needed
to do basic wound care.
This saved them travel
and also a dollar-fifty per visit.
This is a huge amount for a family
that had to sell a part of their property
to finance the operation.
Now Sunita never got the opportunity
to learn how to read or write,
but hundreds of kilometers
from the nearest major hospital,
she confidently led Bino's recovery.
EE: We are heartened by stories
like Bino and Sunita's.
We have only scratched the surface.
Our audacious idea is to ignite
a family caregiver movement
that will revolutionize the way
we experience health care.
Over the next six years,
we will train over 70 million
family caregivers
across India, Bangladesh,
Indonesia and Nepal,
supporting health systems that provide
care to over one billion people.
(Applause)
But Noora can't be everywhere.
And our ultimate dream
is for health systems around the world
to take what we've learned
and make it their own,
to include caregivers, make them
a part of the health care team,
give them confidence, skills, training.
That should be standard practice.
It's almost too obvious,
but we are not there yet.
And that is our collective call to action.
SA: In every caregiver that we train,
I see the triumphs
and the struggles of my mother
caring for my grandmother through
a debilitating neurological condition.
She was the most powerful steward
of my grandmother's care,
yet seemingly invisible in the system.
EE: And I see my 13-year-old self
helping my mom as she recovered
from brain surgery
and relearned how to walk
and talk and feed herself.
To this day, we carry the intimate
understanding of that responsibility,
the deep pride
and the relief that comes
with being part of someone's healing.
At its core, this work is about honoring
one of the most ancient human practices,
helping those we love.
And it's about seeing
compassion and community
as essential medicines.
Just imagine a world where
no matter who you are
or where you're from,
you know exactly how to take care
of your loved ones
and where you are seen
and acknowledged for this essential work.
We see every day that this is possible,
and that in order to change health care,
it takes a family.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)